chaque année des centaines de milliers
de vieux frigos et de climatiseurs
bourré de gaz toxique pour
l'environnement se retrouvent à la rue
puis à la ferraille sans passer par le
recyclage c'est une grave erreur dit le
directeur général de gourous sikhs en
2021 goreux c'est qu'à ramasser
83300 neuf appareils et à éviter ainsi
leur âge de 87 mille tonnes de ges
l'organisme qui regroupe des recycleurs
et des détaillants d'électroménager a
mis sur pied un réseau de 260 points de
dépôt d'appareils en fin de vie utile
tout le monde connaît voisin qui met son
frigo son art climatisé sur le bord de
la rue malheureusement cela paraît hélas
souvent moins dé gaz et donc ce bar
d'arudy essentiellement les gaz sont
rejetées dans l'atmosphère ou sinon
rendu chez le ferrailleur ces gaz qu'on
appelle des halocarbures sont
particulièrement toxique pour
l'atmosphère
au québec plus de 300 mille appareils
réfrigérants sont mal recyclées chaque
année
cousin le rejet de 300 mille tonnes de
ge est ce soit l'équivalent de cent
mille voitures sur nos routes la
meilleure chose à faire c'est de le
rapporter au sort des 1 2 tasse à
domicile cours si tu le souhaites
récupéré 70% des vieux appareils
réfrigérants d'ici 2024 et 90% d'ici
2028 pour y arriver il faut convaincre
les indécis les délinquants et améliorer
la chaîne de transport entre le
consommateur et l'entreprise de
recyclage c'est tout une question aussi
de structures logistiques de volumes
plus en plus ces volumes sont importants
non plus les gains environnementaux sont
importants aussi le gouvernement versera
jusqu'à 90 millions de dollars dans les
10 prochaines années pour soutenir les
efforts de goreux cycle est certain qu'à
partir du moment où le réseau de
récupération sera mature 7 cette
impulsion
budgétaire de la part du gouvernement
n'aura plus sa place les entreprises
spécialisées peuvent récupérer et
recycler jusqu'à 95% des pièces et des
gaz de réfrigérateurs horde usage ici
norma grondin radio canada montréal